it's really
liberating to just take in the
both sides the spin on both sides
it somehow unlocks your mind to like
think on your own
to realize that that i don't know it's
the same thing that was useful right in
the soviet union times for
when when everybody was much more aware
that they're
surrounded by propaganda right it's so
interesting what you're saying actually
so noam chomsky
you know used to be our mit colleague
once said that
propaganda is to democracy what violence
is
to totalitarianism and and
what he means by that is if you have a
really totalitarian government you don't
need propaganda
right people will do what you do what
you want them to do
anyway but out of fear right yes but
otherwise you need propaganda so i would
say actually that the propaganda is much
higher quality
in democracies much more believable and
it's
really brilliant it's really striking
when i talk to colleagues
science colleagues like from russia and
china and so on
i noticed they are actually much more
aware of the propaganda in their own
media than many of my american
colleagues are about the
propaganda and western media that's
brilliant that means the propaganda and
the western media is just better yes
that's so better in the west
[Laughter]
that's good but when you when once you
realize that you realize there's also
something very optimistic there that you
can do about it right
because first of all omissions
as long as there's no outright
censorship
you can just look at both sides and
pretty quickly piece together a much
more accurate idea of what's actually
going on right and develop a natural
skepticism too
yeah just a analytical scientific
mind about how you're taking information
yeah and i i think
i have to say sometimes i feel that some
of us in the academic bubble are
too arrogant about this and somehow
think oh it's just people who aren't as
educated when we are often just as
gullible also you know
we read only our media and and don't see
through things
anyone who looks at both sides like this
in comparison will immediately start
noticing
the shenanigans being pulled and you
know i think
what i tried to do with with this app is
that the
big tech has the some extent uh tried to
blame the individual
for being manipulated much like big
tobacco
tried to blame the individuals entirely
for smoking and then
later on you know our government stepped
up and said actually you know
you can't just blame little kids for
starting to smoke we have to have more
responsible advertising and this and
that
i think it's a bit the same here it's
very convenient for a big tech to blame
so it's just people who are so dumb and
get fooled
the blame usually comes in saying oh
it's just human psychology
people just want to hear what they
already believe but professor david rand
at mit
actually partly debunked that with a
really nice study showing that people
tend to be interested in hearing things
that go against what they believe
if it's presented in a respectful way
like suppose for example
that um you have a company
and you're just about to launch this
project and you're convinced it's going
to work and someone says you know
lex i hate to tell you this but this is
going to fail and here's why
would you be like shut up i don't want
to hear it
yeah would you you would be interested
right and also
if you're on an airplane back in the co
pre-covered times you know
and the guy next to you is clearly from
the opposite side of the political
spectrum
but is very respectful and polite to you
wouldn't you be kind of interested
to hear a bit about how he or she thinks
about things
of course but it's not so easy to find
out
respectful disagreement now because like
for example if you
are a democrat and you're like i want to
see something on the other side so you
just go breitbart.com
and then after the first 10 seconds you
feel deeply insulted by something and
then they it's it's not going to work or
if you take someone who votes republican
and they go to something on the left and
they just get very offended very quickly
by them having put a deliberately ugly
picture of donald trump on the front
page or something
it doesn't really work so this news
aggregator also has this nuanced slider
which you can pull to the right and then
to make it easier to get exposed to
actually more
sort of academic style or more
respectful um
portrayals of different views and and
finally the one kind of bias i think
people are mostly aware of is the left
right right because it's so obvious
because
both left and right are very powerful
here right
both of them have well-funded tv
stations and newspapers and it's kind of
hard to miss
but there's another one the
establishment slider
which is it's also really fun i i i love
to play with it
that's more about corruption yes because
if you have a society
that where almost all the powerful
entities
want you to believe a certain thing
that's what you're going to read in both
the big media mainstream media on the
left and on the right of course
and the powerful companies can push back
very hard
like tobacco companies push back very
hard back in the day when peop
some newspapers started writing articles
about tobacco being dangerous
so it was hard to get a lot of coverage
about it initially
and also if you look geopolitically
right of course
in any country when you read their media
you're mainly going to be reading a lot
about articles about how
our country is the good guy and the
other countries are the bad guys
right so if you want to have a really
more nuanced understanding you know
like the germans used to be told that
the the
the british used to be told that the
french were the bad guys and the french
used to be told that the
british were the bad guys now they
visit each other's countries a lot and
have a much more nuanced understanding i
don't think there's going to be any more
wars between france and germany but on
the geopolitical scale
it's just just as much as ever you know
a big cold war now you as china
and so on and if you want to if you want
to get a more nuanced
understanding of what's happening in
geopolitically then it's really fun to
look at this
establishment slider because it turns
out there are tons of
little newspapers both on the left and
on the right
who sometimes challenge um establishment
and say
you know maybe we shouldn't actually
invade iraq right now maybe this weapons
and mass destruction thing was bs
if you look at the journalism research
afterwards you can actually see that
quite clearly that both
cnn and fox were very pro
let's get rid of saddam there are
weapons of mass destruction
then there were a lot of smaller
newspapers they were like wait a minute
this evidence seems a bit sketchy and
maybe we
but of course they were so hard to find
most people didn't even know they
existed right
yet it would have been better for
american national security if those
voices had also come up
i think it harmed america's national
security actually that we invaded iraq
and arguably there's a lot more interest
in
that kind of thinking too from those
small sources
so like the when you say big it's more
about
kind of uh the reach of the broadcast
but it's not big in terms of the
interest
i think i think there's a lot of
interest in that kind of
anti-establishment or like skepticism
towards
you know out-of-the-box thinking there's
a lot of interest in that kind of thing
you